mr. didn't congratulations on the award
please tell me how did you feel when you
receive the price just an hour ago it
was just wonderful it was one of the
best feelings I think I've ever had and
I love the tradition and being part of
this magic event and this great
celebration of knowledge with all the
royalty in the tradition and the fancy
clothes it's just wonderful Wesley
that's you expected it to be well
physically yes because I've seen the
videos and you know I've seen it what my
friends got it it tastes like that but
it's very special when it's you yourself
the prize money is eight million Swedish
crowns tell me can money buy you
happiness I I think if you were very
very poor and you know if I'd still want
to give me eight million Swedish crowns
when I was twenty years old
hmm it would have made me very happy
indeed but I think you know when you bit
older I'm about to retire and I'm gonna
live off this and other money I say for
the rest of my life but what made me
happy is the professional recognition
the ceremonies wonderful week here in
stock I ask you because you studied the
connection between happiness and bro and
money right and what did you find
well I think what we find is if you
really don't have enough than money
severely interferes with your day to day
enjoyment of life so a lot of things
that are important to doing things with
friends you know maybe watching a sports
event or going out for a meal and if you
don't have enough to do that or you have
this nagging worry about money all the
time then it really does interfere with
living a good life but beyond some point
money is certainly not the most
important thing and it may be not the
most important thing anyway only if it
interferes with the important thing
so these money you get now doesn't mean
anything to you yes
you know you worry a bit about what
might happen in the future I'm very
fortunate in that I have two children
who are financially very successful mhm
so you know there are a lot of people of
my age who worry about what might happen
to their kids and I'm very fortunate
that I don't have that so if not eight
million Swedish crowns makes you have
feet what does Oh my work makes me happy
and I love my work I look forward to
when you would stop now is it I'm gonna
retire but not from doing research and
writing books and writing so I'll retire
from administration and teaching classes
and I'll be freer to travel and do what
I want to do and while I'm still able to
do that much looking forward to that and
fly-fishing is one big interests I've
understood but you're not very good at
it who told you that
your wife because she's much better
she's much better at it than I am
yeah no I'm not I think I've never
become a fanatic about it and become a
real professional and I think for me it
takes it's a totally absorbing activity
that takes your mind away consciously
from the problems I'm working on and
often after a day's fishing I just got
arrived solve the problems anyway oh but
do you think you will have time for
fly-fishing and Oprah I think you I know
you you love will pursue yeah now when
when all this oh I hope so I very much
hope so I think we have to make time for
those things maybe in a year or two yeah
or along the way you know one of the
great innovations of my time is that you
can have a big flat-screen television
and watch our product
oh yeah mister didn't thank you very
much and have a great evening
thank you I'm looking it's been
wonderful so far and I'm sure the rest
evening will be - yeah thank you